the Joe Rogan experience you think
Bernie Sanders maybe could have done
that not goodie of one but what would
happen if he got the problem with Bernie
is the same reason why he let those
black lives people take his mic and
start screaming into the thing like hey
buddy can't do that
you're running for [ __ ] president
you're showing right here that people
can just storm the stage and take the
microphone from you like you should say
I would love to have a dialogue with you
let's do it publicly let's schedule it
now we'll come back we'll get a large
group of people and I'll speak with you
on this stage if you represent this very
important political movement but here's
what you can't do you can't disrespect
this campaign speech because you're
literally stopping people from ever
voting for me if I let you do it because
that's the fact what if he slashed him
do that and then go you can't let kids
just take over your show you can't
you're the guy who's supposed to be
running the country you can't even run
this [ __ ] thing you got this one
thing you're standing on the stage in
front of 300 people three of them just
took your mic congratulations you don't
have leadership ability whatever then
what about other than that that's a big
part that's big that's that's not good
that's not good but you know what in the
moment he made an error that doesn't
mean that's who he is part of the
problem is with people judging you by
these moments that you have right and
they doesn't define him he might have
done that and go well you know I was
just trying to be nice I didn't expect
that
I thought security was gonna get them
out of there but they didn't you know
they didn't did what they wound up on
the stage with him screaming I thought
maybe he didn't I seen him do when he
did those type of things a few times
I'll see the video what is he saying I
thought it was his way of saying look I
get it what it must feel like to not be
able to be heard and it's not my fault
that no one's ever listened to you so
far but what do we have to do and then
maybe he feels they go up and they just
I was a sane person who would lead it
would lead the same person when you
ignore that long to just grab a mic and
maybe he goes I have to be a part of
letting this person spill out a little
yeah but the problem is then who doesn't
spill out everybody can spill out
everybody can jump up for their own
cause whether it's white power or
[ __ ] Jews lives matter whatever it is
you could just decide you have a group
now
your group may very well be valid but
you can just decide now you're just
gonna yell out whenever there's some
sort of a political speech and then
it'll be your chance to talk you're just
gonna take the mic and make it all about
you yeah there's got to be sensible
there are a lot of things we need to be
concerned with we need to be concerned
with war we need we need to be concerned
with poverty education health care all
these different things but you can't
just represent each one of these very
very important groups and jump on stage
everywhere and start yelling do you know
what I thought does that make sense yes
I should be I should be just done with
this you know know why it's cuz the
subject it's like it gets so exhausting
I know let me add one more thing no cuz
I by the way you know you have these
theories in your head and then sometimes
somebody will respond and blow it out it
you know just on your own murder I never
thought about that but I had this theory
it was a weird way that I thought about
it well two things one kids do I'm
stealing from the act a teeny bit but
just because it's a you know stat I use
it kids do if there was a yelp review
young adults have an amazing yelp review
for being on the right side who they who
they root for who they I think music no
you're dealing with some left-wing
democratic out here kids like what you
ever talked to some kids from Alabama
I'm talking about on them the masses of
kids that that March oh the ones that
Maher ones that March the ones that get
involved if you go back and look at like
you know Kent State or you know I'm
sorry I'm Emma I'm sure we could we
could pull up 50 but so with that said
now I'm not saying we shouldn't doubt
them if I had a gun to my head and
someone said if we had a crystal ball
are they making the right choice about
Bernie Sanders these kids and I go ah
let me ask
I got a tournament that for fire I gotta
watch me campaign I gotta watch a debate
I can't how's he gonna hear handle
public policy how's he gonna I can't
just ask I go we're gonna shoot you in
your head I go with kids overwhelmingly
kids like him yeah he's gonna do the
right thing and I think if there was a
crystal ball here's my theory but yeah I
don't know I've never said this I think
out loud that maybe fifty years from now
just like we're learning about history
they would talk about him in the way
that you know this guy came into office
picture kids and they're telling him why
maybe 2022 started to be these good
times and there's and they're talking
about history and they well what guy
came in the office and he really didn't
know anything about the the he didn't
really know about he was not you know he
didn't know about war he didn't know
about no and no one thought he could
really do it but he was one thing that
you wouldn't think would answer our
economical problems you can be a nice
hearted person but that's not gonna
answer your economical problems but it
ended up doing that because he did truly
treat everybody kind and it ended up
that when people started to be treated
fairly if the world worked better with
less depressed people I'm not saying
everybody but people who torture people
we had someone in power that was
overwhelmingly kind right and people
felt the wrath of that almost very
quickly right maybe we got and then you
know what no one ever thought this then
some of the economical problems worked
out the work themselves out now that is
based on no science yeah that but that
was in my head
[Applause]